[Music]  the impression that you have made just  an example the impression that you've  made on all of us he never ever ever  does he disappoint his creations don't  disappoint his imagination doesn't  disappoint I can't tell you what this  means to me I'm I'm thrilled overwhelmed  and you've made this day certainly  totally unforgettable and almost  unbelievable to me years ago I never in  a million years would have thought  they'd be a day like this I just loved  every minute of it Steven Spielberg once  said to me you know Stan you and I do  essentially the same thing except my  characters moved and so now my  characters move to said take that Steven  [Music]  you  you